ابدا معك يونس لتضعنا في صوره اخر الاخبار
هناك طبعا رصدنا محاولات اخراج عدد من
المنكوبين خرجوا بالفعل احياء هل من جديد
في هذا الخصوص
ليلى نحن نعيش قصه مماثله نحن نتابع جهود
عمال الاغاثه والبحث منذ حوالي الساعتين
الان
سمعنا تصفيقات من هذا الفريق للنظرا لانهم
نجحوا في احداث تواصل مع احد العالقين
داخل هذا المبنى حسب ما فهمنا هو سوري
الجنسيه وتواصل مع فرق الانقاذ عبر رساله
الكترونيه بعد مضي اكثر من 110 ساعات على
هذه الهزه الارضيه بعدها طلب من الجميع
الصمت من اجل التاكد من وجوده تم التجاوب
معه استمر بعد ذلك الحفر لحوالي نصف ساعه
من اجل احداث تجويف
يعني تمرير احد عمال الاغاثه من اجل
الوصول اليه هذه المحاولات ما تزال مستمره
حتى الان نتوقع ان يتم اخراجه ان كان ما
زال على قيد الحياه
اي لحظه الان هذه العمليه كما قلت مستمره
منذ ساعتين وهناك حقيقه استبشار بهذه
الاخبار لانه يعيد الامل
لاهالي العالقين بان امكانيه الانقاذ بعد
مرور هذا الوقت ممكنه وبان يعني هناك من
يتشبث بالحياه حتى في اقصى الظروف لا داعي
للتذكير ليلى بالظروف العصيبه التي شهدتها
هذه المنطقه تحديدا خلال الايام الماضيه
حاله من البرد القارس نحن نتخيل وجود شخص
لمده تقارب خمسه ايام داخل هذا الطقس
البارد جدا دون اكل دون ماوى يعني دون
الدفء مع ذلك هناك من يتشبث بالحياه
ويحاول التواصل مع العالم الخارجي فمن
ايضا بان هناك خمسه اشخاص داخل هذا البيت
تم التاكد بان احدهم على الاقل ما يزال
على قيد الحياه بانتظار اخراجه في ايه
لحظه في هذه الاثناء تستمر اعمال يعني
التنقيب ورفع الانقاض في محاوله الوصول
للمزيد من الناجين اذا لاحظت الى هناك
انتشار مكثف لعناصر الجيش وعناصر الشرطه
بالنظر الى ان هذا المبنى الذي كان يتشكل
من خمسه طوابق احد المحلات الموجوده في
الطابق الاول ومحل لبيع الذهب وهناك مخاوف
من انتشار عمليات السلب والنهب الوصول الى
هذا المحل وبالتالي هذا يبرر انتشار
الامني المكثف لحمايه حتى الممتلكات
المتضرره جراء هذا يعني الزلزال وهذا تحدي
من بين جمله من التحديات التي تواجهها
الحكومه التركيه والدوله التركيه هذه
الكارثه حقيقه حصلت في دقيقه لكن تبعاتها
ما تزال يعيشها الجميع حتى الان والدليل
مئات الالاف من سكان هذه الولايه
والولايات العشر المتضرره الذين ما يزالون
يبيتون في الشوارع دون ماوى دون مصادر
للدف دون غذاء وبالتالي هناك بوس لوجستي
حقيقي فيما يتعلق بتوفير الماوى لهؤلاء
وهناك حديث على ان الحكومه التركيه حتى
الان وفرت الماوى ل 130 الف من اصل 13
مليون
شخص متضرر هذه يعني 130 الف شخص مبلغ يعني
عدد كبير لكنه لا يشكل سوى واحد في المئه
فقط من اعداد المتضررين من هذا الزلزال
بالتالي هناك تم يعني بدل جهد جبار لكن
المزيد والمزيد والمزيد مطلوب لاحتواء
تداعيات هذه الكارثه